these votes book supporters have just
had this banner printed the Aloha vulva
is the bundesliga team's biggest fan
club and motohama is its chairman now a
pensioner
he worked at Volkswagen for 46 years
VW still plays a huge role in his life
my son works there the whole family
works there we depend on VW we're
hopeful that we'll survive the crisis
voice bug is VW isn't it everything
here's VW its influence extends for 50
kilometers without VW there'd be nothing
going on here just farming and raising
cattle without VW the votes for
top-flight team wouldn't exist either
the Bundesliga club is a wholly owned
subsidiary of the VW Group it's only
thanks to the car maker that Boasberg
could afford for example to pay millions
for top players like striker Boz dost
but what will happen if VW has to cut
costs the firm lost 1.6 billion euros
last year after setting aside a huge
amount to cover the costs of the
emissions-cheating scandal so are the
good times over for volkspark Bundesliga
club I believe there's a feel-good
factor at work and when dark clouds
suddenly appear then people get worried
they ask themselves how this could have
happened can the problem be fixed and so
forth for us VW isn't only figures and
the numbers of car sold Volkswagen is
also our employer
it's about Kiba
and that goes for the entire city more
than half of votes pugs 120,000
residents work for the carmaker they've
heard enough about the
emissions-cheating scandal vid and don't
want to talk about it some have turned
their anger towards America they drive
around in their dodge Rams which emit
who knows how much pollution and then
they rail against our diesels sorry I
just don't get it everything invokes
Berg depends on VW's financial health
right next to the car plant is the auto
stat an attraction completely funded by
VW buyers can pick up their new cars
here but also attend concerts and dance
performances the pheno Science Center
also receives money from VW as does the
bottle and water park so the people of
votes Park are worried about their
city's future basically those who did it
put the brands good reputation on the
line and it really is a quality brand
they went too far and didn't think about
this city others have just as many
skeletons in their closets yet they
condemned us for decades the city has
enjoyed a steady stream of business tax
revenue hundreds of millions of euros
from VW alone annually but this year the
car maker will pay much less so the
mayor has already slashed city
expenditures and he might have to
tighten the belt even more we assume
that we still have one or two austerity
budgets ahead of us and at some point
we'll probably have to go into debt but
I only view that as a serious problem if
our debt burden grows too high if we
aren't able to get out of debt quickly
many votes Berg residents are now
holding on to their money as store
owners like boon Hilda Kaiser can
testify she's been in the jewelry
business for over 60 years and sales are
falling for the first time in ages the
business media took home four see folks
don't know what the future holds so
they've started saving like squirrels
preparing for the winter window folks
pardon and votes Berg the company and
the city stand together in good times
and in bad and it looks like the bad
times might be far from over